ماذا تريد اسرائيل من هذا
الاغتيال بالنظر الى
الساحه التي جرى فيها هذا الاغتيال لصالح
العاروري مستشار نتنياهو يحاول ان
يحيد حزب الله ولكنه يتوعد قاده حماس
والمقاومه تحياتي لك اخي حسن ولضيفك
الكريم وساده المشاهدين ما تريده اسرائيل
هو ان تحصد انجازا لطالما تاقت اليه منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب حتى حتى هذه اللحظه
النشوه التي يبديها الاعلام الاسرائيلي
وقيادات سياسيه اسرائيليه تشي
بحجم حاجه اسرائيل الى هذا المشهد لتسوق
الى الداخل الاسرائيلي على انه انتصار
وانتصار كبير
و يعني لم يمنع استمرار هذه الحاله المنتش
في اسرائيل سوى ما عممه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي على قيادات سياسيه بعدم الحديث
في هذا ال الامر لكن واضح جدا بانه
اسرائيل تريد هذه الصوره وهي تحاول ان
تضخها في الداخل الاسرائيلي على انها يعني
صوره انتصار كبير ثم مساله اخرى القضيه
تتجاوز فقط رغبه اسرائيل في الحصول على
صوره انتصار نتنياهو وبعد حاله الضائقه
الشديده جدا التي عاشها في حرب غزه منذ
ثلاثه شهور و هذا الطوق الذي يشتد خناق
عليه سياسيا وعسكريا
ومجتمعيا يريد ان
يهرب الى تنفيس الحاله الداخليه في
اسرائيل من خلال افتعال ربما هذه الحرب في
الاقليم وجر حزب الله الى رد يقود المنطقه
ويقود اسرائيل ونتنياهو شخصيا الى ان
يتملص من دفع استحقاقات الاثمان الكبيره
جدا التي يدفع اليها المجتمع يوميا وهذه
الحرب تخدم مصلحه نتنياهو ومصلحه اليمين
الذي
يريدها ويريد استمرارها الى ما لا نهايه
اليوم استطلعت الراي تقول بان 15% فقط
يؤيدون استمرار نتنياهو في اداء مهامه
كرئيس الوزراء ويعلم نتنياهو بان الساعه
قادمه للحساب مع هذا المجتمع وبالتالي
السبيل الوحيد الى محاوله الهروب الى
الامام هي ان يفجر حربا في الاقليم خاصه
مع انه لم يعد بامكانه ان يسوق انتصارا
ايا يكن في حربه على غزه وقد استنفذ كلكل
اهدافه من هذه الحرب وبالتالي الان الساحه
الوحيده المتاحه الان هي ان يجر حزب الله
خاصه بعد هذا التصعيد الكبير الذي حدث على
امتداد هذه المواجهه وخاصه مع يعني حاله
الضائقه التي يعيشها ايضا المجتمع
الاسرائيلي في شمال فلسطين المحتله